merci monsieur le président merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse au premier ministre monsieur
le premier ministre
mes collègues philippe bas bruno
retailleau et hervé marseille viennent
de déposer une proposition de loi pour
organiser dans des conditions
irréprochables second tour des élections
municipales elle a été intégrée à fait
notre collègue cédric perrin déposé il
ya maintenant plusieurs semaines est
adopté ce matin même par la commission
des lois
cette proposition doit deux ambitions
adapter les opérations de vote
un contexte épidémique persistant et
faciliter l'établissement des
procurations adapter les opérations de
vote c'est garantir aux électeurs qu'ils
pourront exercer leur droit de vote sans
risque pour eux mêmes ni pour leurs
proches c'est aussi permettre aux
candidats à leurs représentants et aux
membres des bureaux de vote de
participer au déroulement et au
dépouillement du scrutin en toute
sécurité
je ne sollicite ici aucune faveur mais
la considération élémentaires que la
république doit à ses concitoyens
faciliter l'établissement des
procurations c'est permettre à chaque
électeur de détenir deux procurations de
voter pour un des ses parents proches
dans une autre commune de celle où il
réside c'est aussi la possibilité donnée
à une personnes fragiles âgées isolées
ou malades d'établir une procuration à
son domicile
là encore il ne s'agit que de respecter
l'équité républicaine
il n'y a pas de société démocratique
sans le vote citoyen le freiner ou le
tronquée serait un sacrilège
après l'abstention les frustrations du
premier tour ce second tour est attendu
depuis de nombreuses semaines
nous devons vous devez permettre la
participation du plus grand nombre
d'électeurs
nous devons vous devez faire la loi qui
lui garantira monsieur le premier
ministre nous avons tout mis en oeuvre
pour adopter en moins d'une semaine les
textes sur l'état d'urgence sanitaire et
sa prorogation
alors ma question est très simple êtes
vous prêts à utiliser tous les moyens
constitutionnels à votre disposition
pour faire aboutir ces mesures
électorale indispensable avant le 15
juin afin qu'elles puissent être mises
en oeuvre dans de bonnes conditions le
28 merci pour vous répondre la parole et
au secrétaire d'état auprès du ministre
intérieur chez laurent du neige j'avais
la parole monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice r effectivement aujourd'hui au
conseil des ministres
est inscrit à l'ordre du jour le décret
de convocation des électeurs pour le
deuxième tour des élections municipales
qui se tiendra le 28 juin qui va
concerner un peu plus de 16 millions
d'électeurs un peu moins de 2,5 milles
commune et cette décision a été prise
par le premier ministre après évidemment
qui a été rendu l'avis du conseil
scientifique le 18 mai dernier qui a
prévu un certain nombre de conditions
sanitaires dans lesquelles le scrutin de
voix devra se tenir à la fois pour la
campagne électorale est bien évidemment
à la fois pour l'organisation des
opérations de vote au moment même où on
se parle et je viens d'ailleurs de
quitter cette réunion que je vais
rejoindre aussitôt nous recevons avec le
ministre de l'intérieur dit d'autres
ministres les chefs des partis
politiques de notre pays puis nous
aurons une réunion ensuite avec les
associations d'élus pour discuter de ce
que seront ces modalités qui permettront
je reprends vos propos madame la
sénatrice d'organiser ces élections dans
des conditions irréprochables à la fois
en termes juridiques et à la fois en
termes bien évidemment de protection
sanitaire de nos concitoyens alors bien
sûr plusieurs pistes seront évoqués le
fait de faciliter les procurations le
fait de préconiser d'avoir la
possibilité pour les électeurs de
pouvoir porter effectivement un masque
l'aménagement des bureaux de vote comme
nous l'avions fait en partie pour le
premier tour mais d'autres
préconisations est émise par le conseil
scientifique et nous travaillons
évidemment à la mise en oeuvre de ces
dispositifs alors bien sûr il ya
d'autres demandes
vous en avez cité une très précise qui
est la possibilité d'élargir le champ
d'application juridique des procurations
pas seulement les facilités mais élargir
le champ juridique l'ensemble de ces
questions seront à l'étude
et je puis vous garantir que nous y
attelons dans un esprit d'ouverture mais
aussi de sécurité juridique pour donner
et reprendre l'exemple que vous avez
cités celui des procurations
je vous rappelle que juridiquement et
les principes qui s'appliquent et qui
veulent que pour une procuration
il faut qu'en tout moment puisse
vérifier l'identité du mandant de celui
qui donne procuration et en même temps
vérifier son consentement donc c'est à
l'aune de l'ensemble de ces principes
que nous allons nous examinerons dans un
esprit de grande ouverture l'ensemble
des discussions fin l'ensemble des
mesures dont découleront les discussions
qui sont actuellement en cours
voilà madame darcos merci monsieur
secrétaire d'état vous pensez bien qu'il
ya urgence nous sommes
quasiment nous sommes à un mois les
procurations c'est essentiel il faut
qu'ils aient un plus grand nombre qu'ils
puissent voter savez très bien que
d'emmener d'envoyer un objet directement
à domicile ou même de faire des
permanences dans certaines communes pour
que les pays puissent récupérer les
procurations
ça nous aidera beaucoup et ça donnera la
démocratie merci merci la parole et l
autre collègue annie guillemot pour le
groupe social